[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANKUSH AGARWAL: Hi.
Ankush here.
I'm a software engineer
here at Google Cloud.
KELLY GROVER: And
hi from me, Kelly.
I'm a program manager
on the training team.
On this episode, we'll look at
Cloud SQL, a managed service
that helps make the management
of MySQL and Postgres databases
far less painful.
ANKUSH AGARWAL:
We'll be taking you
through a quick demo of a
self-paced lab where we'll
create and connect to a
Cloud SQL MySQL instance
and perform some
basic SQL operations.
So stick around for that.
KELLY GROVER: If you're
using a Postgres database
engine, no problem.
We'll point you to
that lab as well.
ANKUSH AGARWAL: Cloud SQL is a
fully managed database service
that lets you hand off to
Google the often time-consuming
yet necessary tasks.
Think of applying patches and
updates or managing backups
and configuring replications.
This allows you to focus
on building great apps.
KELLY GROVER: Whether you're
using MySQL or Postgres,
Cloud SQL allows you to set
up and configure an instance
in just a few steps.
For better performance,
you can keep your data
close to the
services that need it
by selecting the most suitable
geographical region to run
your resources.
ANKUSH AGARWAL:
This hands-on lab
shows you how to create and
connect to a Cloud SQL MySQL
instance and perform basic
SQL operations using the GCP
Console and the MySQL Client.
KELLY GROVER: And we
haven't forgotten about you,
if you use Postgres.
We have a lab just for you.
Either one will take about
30 minutes to complete,
and you can check out the links
to start the Qwiklabs here.
At this point in the lab, we've
enabled the Cloud SQL API,
created a Cloud SQL
instance, and connected
to the instance using the
MySQL Client in Cloud Shell.
Now, we are going to create a
SQL database on the Cloud SQL
instance.
We are going to insert sample
data into the guestbook
database we created.
We're going to retrieve
the data and see
the two guests we added.
ANKUSH AGARWAL: We hope
you enjoyed this episode.
You're welcome to
share your experiences
or ideas of using Cloud SQL
in the Comments section below.
KELLY GROVER: If you
haven't already done so,
check out the link where
you can apply what you've
learned using a $300 free
trial credit on Google Cloud
Platform.
ANKUSH AGARWAL: All of our
additional training resources
are linked below.
Thanks again for watching
and see you soon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]